[Music]
what was it like for your families to
see that movie on the screen last night
my nephew's like we're really you know
they were they were there and they were
like really uh blown away by it and it's
good they couldn't believe that they
were like it's such an amazing film you
know they were caught up in it all I did
get into something that I love you I
have to get back okay how's this gonna
go and ian has it's gonna go he can you
know about the kids were in the car you
know they were just so thrilled to be
then to be surrounded by all of that it
was I think it was such a big if so
inspired Majan tree of last night really
kind of took me I felt like that I was
that little girl from Missouri again
with you know waiting for and looking
forward to so it's like you couldn't you
can't go yeah you know yeah you try to
meet that film to meet black Benton you
you need to sort of step up to that
Courtney said you weren't giving any
secrets away I know you guys were sworn
to secrecy but what's the what's the
what's the best thing someone tried to
do to get some information about the
movie out of you
I was so yeah I'm doing something you
can't talk about this you don't suck
I don't know when to top it like don't
ask me anything anybody about anything
about it if it's like posted you know
before you go on to the set right yeah
and if they give you it right they want
the script back we don't have any really
make it with you you took it and they
came together they sent you a rewrite a
page that came back for that page you
know I was like you gonna come all the
way back how about we put him on
FaceTime and we shredded it you have to
believe that I'm shredding the page
though don't you oh they were not going
through all of that I was not to say
exactly early reviews are already out
for the film and they're very very good
and very positive a lot of people are
calling this Marvel's most political
bill so what does that mean for you to
be a part of what people are considering
the most daring and political film that
Barbara was made I think it's a it's a
first you know in in so many ways you
know in terms of you know records and
box-office records that is breaking in
terms of being the you know the first
black superhero in terms of you know the
themes that they're addressing in the
movie you know it's you know tremendous
entertainment but so much that we're
familiar with and that that resonates
you know from history to till now it's
so modern it's so you know steeped in in
in our history as a people you know in
our our separation in our resilience
it's so it's it's marvelous that market
like so many issues even like migration
issues yes and go from country to
country you did deals I think but I
think and this super message of like
that we're all responsible for each
other is very powerful that it has in
the film as well as a female
as well as I think what the still
messages you know would kill monger for
me which is like this what you could
become he could have been king but
because of the circumstances of his life
but what's been pushed through him when
he diddled him into the person that he
is and then ultimately he's never gonna
feel free he says you know I'd rather
die than be incarcerated facing that
stuck with me because I mean you know I
felt like that that that could have been
written in in any movie about the black
experience in America anywhere it was a
very universal theme and when he said
that I was like I know it you know yeah
it hit me also you know cuz we read
those stories in history where mothers
have sacrificed their children instead
of allowing them to become enslaved on
planes who jumped off you know the side
of the ship instead of you know he'd be
going into bondage you know so some of
us know exactly perd that we know that
we loved
lived and studied that it's like oh
quickly I know that I know that you guys
you you put a lot of your heart and your
soul into this but when we were in the
panel Ryan Coogler called you his mentor
yeah how does that make you feel knowing
that this man looks to you as someone
who has shaped and guided his career and
look at where his career I know you know
I feel fortunate it's in the universe
brings people together at the right
moments and that I was able to then he
felt comfortable to trust me enough to
be able to be a part of his journey the
beginning of his journey
I think he's got so much to do so much
to say I think that was clear to me his
moral compass in what he was trying to
do I mean he was working his social work
even when we were talking at that time
when that time he was like working in
prisons and stuff
when Ryan is someone who cares so much
so deeply to help any part in life as
you did in this to to lift that in some
way and allow his vision to be she'd
seen his a is a beautiful thing and then
it comes out with black panther and I
was just I don't know I you know it's
just this overwhelming thing is it any
wonder
seriously that yes is mentored because
they they they share that same type
spirit quiet dignity yes yeah that's
very passion and love you know so I see
in Ryan what I see in Felton forest when
he directed to friend all these years
that's right he did they get the great
opportunity
[Music]